[Music]
it's inspiring to see and a woman from
Norway betting on herself to to do these
things and so showing the journey and
any self-doubt you might have this is
why I went to Toronto you know like most
people won't do this kind of thing come
here and that's so true like every time
I share that I'm here people are like
wow it's so inspiring your job as a
thought leader is to teach people to
think like you think so it's bringing
people into how did you develop this
mindset it's not doing it to show off
and look at how fabulous my life is but
it's to take people behind the thought
process proc that you have so that
you're teaching them a way to think that
they can apply to their life doesn't
mean that they go join some expensive
Mastermind in a different country right
but it may encourage them to seek help
yeah or to take an online conference or
something to realize that they don't
have to stay
stuck well we're here for another
one-on-one we've got Anakin is's part of
the Mastermind and we're spending some
time together so what's on your mind how
can I help so many things good that's a
good start well mainly it's growing my
YouTube channel uh you know I just
recently started the channel after I was
here last time and you challenge me
haven't been putting much work into it
to be honest for several reasons it just
hasn't been you know the it hasn't been
scheduled but the plan is now to really
Build and Grow the YouTube channel so
like there's several things of course
and we did talk a little bit about that
when we did the live show two weeks ago
um and there's one thing I'm you know
thinking of how to like balance
promoting my podcast and the YouTube
channel and I know that we talked a
little bit about that and you said that
okay for example really good advice was
okay uh if you um promote uh the Youtube
uh like films on Instagram people are
not in the mode for longterm content
especially if you're linking to the
actual episode yes so somebody's coming
from
Instagram they're in an instant mind
mindset they're looking through your
stories it's like 15 seconds at a time
you know they're not ready to go watch a
half hour video of you talking about
personal development or whatever to gain
subscribers it could be helpful and
you're releasing episodes once a it's
once a week now once a week and it will
be two times so one is like up until to
now it has been the same as the podcast
yeah so uh in a few weeks when I'm
finished with my book let's go I'll
schedule are you talking about the book
on your content
uh not yet I did neck surgery a few
months ago and my energy level has been
like I haven't had the same the normal
capacity now I'm back I feel strong
focused in a couple of days I'm finished
with my book and then it's all YouTube
so how do I do it so showing the process
of you doing the book oh yeah is
content so like you want to how do you
do that like in like obviously in on
Instagram I do talk about the book okay
uh like how would I transform that into
like a YouTube uh episode whatever
you're working on right now with the
book so like Instagram and YouTube pair
great together Instagram is just a
shorter version of what you would post
as a long form video on YouTube yeah so
if you're talking about the book if
you're going to make a 10-minute video
what I did with my book the first one
was I would write from a Whole Foods and
it would take me about half hour to walk
to the Whole Foods and so I would film
me walking to the whole foods give an
update about what was going to do with
the book like what my goal was today
with the book what half hour I wouldn't
do a half hour update but I would talk
about what I was hoping to write about
you know on my way there I'm walking the
Whole Foods I'm about to write today I'm
trying to get through these sections and
why it's so important so I'm kind of
teaching but I'm also talking about the
book and then uh I would always ask
people for questions and so on the next
episode I would answer the questions in
the first episode so I would talk for 15
minutes talking about the book and the
next 15 minutes would be me answering
people's questions
now I'd be walking and so uh this is
before my cell phone was good enough to
do it's like the old school like
camcorder so I'd be walking down busy
streets with this giant camera like this
and a piece of paper like this to
people's questions whatever that was my
process fantastic and so every week I
had a new video talking about the book
and so people were involved in the
growing of the book so we're building
attention and hype for the book taking
people throughout the process so you've
already written the book so whatever but
I'm done writing my book hey hey you
guys didn't know I've been writing a
book for the past X number of months and
it's almost ready to go and what the
book is about and some of the lessons
and what you've learned about the
process of writing the book are you
working with a publisher or you doing it
yourself doing like I have self
publishing through a publisher okay like
yeah so next is you're going to give it
to an editor yeah she like she's been
through the manuscript like twice so I'm
working on the third round now it's
going to go up oh you're pretty close
okay have you done the artwork no okay
so that's next artwork right the
description uh for the book are you
doing art work inside the book like all
of these things you can start to talk
about like on YouTube well both yeah
YouTube long form and Instagram short
form I'm thinking about these three
covers what do you think that's a quick
Instagram post like this cover this
cover this I don't know what do you guys
think these four covers what do I pick
so clever because I thought like all the
YouTube films need to be like powerful
thought lader stuff so yes yeah but like
taking people these videos won't do as
well for views but for your audience and
building relationship it's great to have
a series to show the things that you're
working on and then just teaching
lessons inside it so if I'm picking
between the four books covers right if
you're going to make a long form video
about that what's a what's a lesson that
you're going to teach me you can use the
book as not just a vlog of I did this
and I did this and I did this that
that's not teaching me anything but what
am I learning through this because with
everything you're teaching there's
always a story always yeah right so
you're teaching me a lesson but there's
a story attached to it so that the
lesson makes sense which is probably
what you're doing in all your training
everything else anyway right great so
just make the story related to the book
super so the story is picking the four
covers what's the lesson I mean it could
be tons of lessons whether it's about
you didn't believe in yourself you could
even write a book or getting feedback
from clients
or the imagery that you're putting on
the covers like there's a lot of
different always a lot tons right so I
don't know if you normally start when
you're teaching with a lesson or a
story but in this case we have a story
that then we're wrapping a lesson
around so it could even still be
powerful thought leadership content and
the story is the book and what you're
working on M yeah that's 10 minute video
such a good idea and like so you like
could it be even with my phone walking
down yeah the road or yeah if you wanted
to even follow the thought leadership
template you could still think that's
going to be your story that's going to
come later what's a powerful opinion so
what's the lesson so you have the story
you know that okay out of the story we
need to develop a lesson yeah now that
we have a lesson what's the powerful
opinion and you could still do powerful
opinion still same format and then the
story becomes the book so your editor
you know that you could talk about
working with great people how to find
great people and the importance of
having people in your life who support
you on your dreams I mean that's such a
good idea cuz I I love sharing that
stuff yeah and then for example like
with me I've got I'm working on my book
and my editor oh my God she's been such
a lifesaver I can't imagine we do three
rounds she thinks I'm I don't know how
she does think I'm crazy all the things
that are coming back this book is so
much better because of her and the the
the choosing to work with somebody
instead of me trying to do everything
myself has saved me so much time and
freedom and Sanity for example she just
found this typo and then like whatever
whatever is actually coming up I'm just
making stuff up about why you love her
but the lesson then becomes work with
great people or don't do everything
yourself or don't go It Alone amazing
because that means I can start making
those films earlier than what I thought
so it you know you can just start doing
it doesn't have to be fancy it just for
any of your programs right cuz I know
you've been so good at launches like
launch and then nothing and then launch
right launching the me it's open for
however many weeks or whatever a couple
days and then close it down but we want
to show the process yeah so even if
you're going to open up your next launch
again the 3 months leading up to it what
are you working on what are you thinking
about how are you putting team in place
what are the what's going to be
different what are you working what are
the some of the fun things that you're
planning and teaching me while building
hype for the thing yeah I like doing
that stuff on Instagram like i' I've
been using Instagram for a long time so
it's just easy for me to share that
stuff in stories yeah and it's just
taking that and putting into YouTube
sort it takes a little more thought
behind it so instead of like here's my
book coming out there's four there's
four covers
what do you guys think let me know right
that's that's your Instagram story
normally a little bit deeper than that
but yeah yeah I get it you give like a
minute total to be able to talk about it
right yeah versus okay we're going to go
for 10 we're going to start with a
powerful opinion you have more
opportunity to teach and you're a great
teacher it's just a muscle that you need
to build but it's not one that you're
not capable of
doing and now we have weekly content
coming out talking about the book or the
yeah whatever so you're saying length
like 10 minutes or more like what would
10 minute Plus at least yeah 10 minute
plus if you go longer go longer if you
have more to share I can talk for hours
well then do hours are great hours Works
hours is the best if you follow the
template which you don't have to but
it's a good structure especially at the
beginning to kind of figure things out
if you go with the opinion and then you
share the story about the book okay so
you're taking me deep as to why you know
you're hiring great people if we use
your editor as an example cool like that
might be five to seven minutes between
the opinion and the story okay but then
teach me how to do it so if you're
trying to find somebody on your team to
support you here's how you do it and
give three tips yeah and then inside
each of those three tips you could have
a mini example or story now that's a 30
minute video if you want it to be or a
10-minute video or 12 minute video so if
you go advice Story three tips that's an
easy 15minute template every time and
that could be either memorized or you
can write it on a sticky
note just point form yeah and that's
your structure for like you don't have
to memorize it no I I don't do
memorizing I normally just have some
points and then I yeah sticky note yeah
point one two three press recording good
idea there you go there's a free video
every week for promoting it yeah I mean
if you're doing one to two a week and
you wanted to promote from Instagram you
know you've had a lot of traction
already in the podcast so you're getting
results there and the and the YouTube is
newer um you could easily on release do
the audio podcast and then that story
expires in 24 hours and the next day put
it to YouTube but I would put it to the
subscribe to the channel you could say
new video about how to hire people on
your team but the link is to subscribe
to the channel not to the specific video
so they can watch it on their own pace
because they're not going to watch it in
the moment no they're going to watch 40
seconds of it and then go back yeah I've
never seen anybody's Instagram watch
time be amazing no always crap yeah
because you went through the analytics
and you saw that a lot of people because
we've been sending people from Instagram
yeah oh yeah we looked at yours
specifically right how long was it short
yeah it's going to be like 20 40 seconds
this be it to be really small which
which makes sense you know so uh like
for the podcast I normally send out an
email talking about the podcast so I'm
just like how do I balance out how I
promote the the podcast and the YouTube
channel the podcast
benefit is what like to have a bigger
audience on the podcast gets you what
the podcast has been to get people to
hear about me and the work I do and
that's how I've been selling my courses
mainly I love for things to prove
themselves so if you're already doing it
with the podcast and you're worried that
promoting the YouTube takes away from
the podcast no I'm not worried I just
like what is the smartest way to be able
to promote both or maybe just go for the
YouTube channel for a while uh you can
do I do one email a week two emails a
week I'm like no I wouldn't do two
emails with the exact same thing no
Instagram you can get away with it in
the stories because it may not it's a
different day it's not showing up in the
same feed at the same time but email you
want to be respectful people's emails
like what's new that I'm getting in this
one uh I would do both here's the
podcast or watch it on YouTube I've got
a YouTube channel too it's also there on
YouTube If you wanted to flip it to just
YouTube that is great but it if that
detracts from your podcast and the
podcast is how you gener Revenue right
now yeah the podcast is how I generate
revenue and I think that YouTube will
you know take over a lot of that in the
future I'm still testing I have no idea
how YouTube will work in norwegen and as
I talked about like people in Norway
they are so used to watching like
English content I've never like if I
want to figure something out I don't
write in Norwegian how to blah blah blah
it's always how to whatever in English
yeah but they don't have to be searching
for it no videos would be recommended
even if they're not searching for it and
that was a question also like okay so if
somebody's watching English content will
my Norwegian content be recommended if
they are from nor Norway if they're
watching related things yeah so what
happens is if you start to build your
audience on your YouTube channel or you
send some email out and people start to
watch and you start building a a base on
YouTube doesn't have to be a big base
but what ends up happening is who are
the people who are watching from your
channel they going to be people who are
in Norway who speak Norwegian who care
about these kinds of topics personal
development kinds of topics YouTube will
start to recommend them your videos more
because they've watched one of your
videos but if they start watching a lot
of your videos it'll start recommending
it to people who are like them yeah so
other people who are from Norway who
care about person in development who
have a similar profile who've never
heard of you who might be just watching
Tom B Channel or my Channel or whatever
right and then all of a sudden wait what
but if they see it in Norwegian it's
like wow somebody's making content in
Norwegian even though I'm used to watch
it in English and me go watch it here
when we do subtitles um in Spanish for
example and and I mean a lot of the
languages we've done subtitles
in even if they're in the US they'll
switch it to their language so our
Spanish channel has a big audience in
the US they speak English they're
looking in English but they switch it to
Spanish because they'd rather consume it
in their native language they'll do it
in English if they have to you know
people in normally speak English at a
pretty high rate but theyd still rather
consume it in their own language and
have to go through the process of
understanding and not all the words may
make sense and if they're new to
personal development they may not
understand some of the things you're
saying but in the native language is a
lot easier yeah so it'll start get
getting recommended to people who are
like the ones watching your
videos and then they see you pop up with
Norwegian titles and and thumbnails like
who's this interesting so the trick is
and I'll show you I'll show you how to
do it at Mastermind that when you're
sharing a link to a
video it goes to a playlist of all your
videos so that we control where they go
next so that when the video ends it
automatically goes to another video on
your Channel as opposed to the video
ending yeah so if we can train people
that when they watch one video they
watch five they watch eight yeah other
people are going to start seeing your
videos a lot more who are like them and
geography is a big part of that nice
yeah that's so
exciting yeah a new world so okay so up
until like I have that weekly podcast
episode I'm going to put it out on
YouTube right or you're not going to put
up on YouTube no my plan is to just
continue putting it up because I haven't
more you though cuz you're you're at
least the ones last time we saw was it's
just a it's because a lot of things
leading up to yeah so normally it's more
me more you leave with a powerful
opinion I'd love to see coaching I don't
think I've seen a coaching one yet no
but I have a lot of them uh on the
podcast great yeah not on YouTube yet
even if you take some of the old ones
and put them on YouTube yeah as long as
it's still relevant yeah so if we had a
mix of
you solo you coaching and then than you
doing the book MH or the launch of
whatever and if you run out of time
great you cut up you cut back one of
them but the coaching one I I want to
see because that's what you're selling
the group coaching but then also your
high-end one-on-one coaching or the
mastermine coaching that you're going to
create yeah it's great that you're
writing the book and it's great that
you're you can talk to the camera but I
don't know that you're a great
coach I I want to see you coaching yeah
I do often take on people have been from
my course and talk about that process
yeah which is good but then you coach
them right yeah yeah so even if you have
old
ones you put it in as long as you don't
say today is whatever date people don't
know so you could take some of the
archive stuff and you do hot seats in
your training too right it's something
you can ask them yeah hey would you mind
if we put this up as a YouTube video
yeah or you set an expectation that if
somebody raises their hand then that's
also going to be be turned into a
YouTube video Yeah to get the one-on-one
time with you good idea um yeah so
continue with episodes from the podcast
and do one other one and then just
switch up the themes for those episodes
and then yeah yeah like you may not even
have to film new coaching videos no if
you're already doing it inside of your
program it's
just either asking them for permission
or setting it if you're not getting up
people saying yes set it as a new
standard that anybody who asked a
question it might be turned into a
YouTube video so the ones who raise
their hands can be the ones who CU
you're doing that work anyway yeah how
often do you do your training uh in the
membership it's twice a month twice a
month and then what happens how long is
it uh an hour and a half and it just
depends on how the process goes an hour
and a half and then how many coaching is
in there depends sometimes I teach
sometimes it's coaching it's yeah okay
so but for sure there can be stuff from
there and then the course maybe yeah
showing the process of what you're
building yeah because it's also I think
really inspirational for your market
like when we
met uh a couple months ago you were
saying you know you're part of this
group in Norway and you know all the
biggest people who are kind of doing
launches and they're big but it's also
not like giant
numbers right but but and that's fine
but it's like it's it's um it's
inspiring to see you doing this yeah
it's in it's inspiring to see someone
from Norway and a woman from Norway
betting on herself to to do these things
and so showing the journey and any
self-doubt you might have or any
concerns you might have or any this is
why I went to Toronto you know like most
people won't do this kind of thing come
here and that's so true like every time
I share that I'm here people are like
wow it's so inspiring and I really like
one of the things things I want to is to
just help people believe that everything
is possible that they can do whatever
they want to that's a good
word there it was but your job as a
thought leader is to teach people to
think like you think you see things
differently and it's normal for you you
coming yeah I'm coming to Toronto like
of course yeah and I'm going to go
surfing in California before and he's
like of course but that's weird right
for most people in Norway when they look
at that it's like what this is some
Crazy Life that she's living and it is
crazy but it's not crazy for you this is
just you living so it's bringing people
into how did you develop this mindset
yeah to believe that you could even do
this to to launch a course to join
masterminds to fly around the world to
meet people it's it's a different way of
thinking it's not doing it to show off
and say look at how fabulous my life is
but it's a take people behind the
thought process that you have so that
you're teaching them a way to think that
they can apply to their life doesn't
mean that they go join some expensive
Mastermind in a different country right
maybe it does but it may encourage them
to seek help yeah or to take an online
conference or something to realize that
they don't have to stay stuck so
something where you're showing the
process of what you're building like it
starts with the book cool but when the
book is done then it's marketing the
book so you can show how you're
marketing the book and your plans when
that's done it's whatever the next thing
is that you're you're going to launch
your Mastermind you're going to launch
your next course you're going to
whatever the thing is that you're doing
next you're launching a YouTube channel
even that it's like I don't know what
I'm doing I don't know like I had
nothing now I have a channel I'm working
on this I got I asked for help I flew to
Toronto to talk to a guy who's got a lot
of subscribers because I hope that a
strategies help me because I don't know
what I'm doing right like even that
process so you document the process of
you building the things that you're
building cuz a lot of people would be
too embarrassed to start a YouTube
channel yeah or to post a video and
doesn't get views and then they stop
yeah or like nobody watches videos in
Norwegian or any of those issues right
that you talk through and say okay but
I'm going to go and give it a shot and
the willingness to try becomes an
inspiration for people to watch say huh
so even talk around the process of
because I was like no there's no point
in making a Norwegian YouTube channel
right remember yeah so even doing
something around that on the channel
yeah yeah yeah but what's the lesson
yeah of course okay but so what would
you say like that's the story but what's
the lesson yeah there are some good
lessons there well pick one that you
have limiting beliefs because you want
to protect yourself great and you say
and that still happens to me yeah I'm
not perfect right I've overcome a lot of
limiting beliefs and I still have more
for example will still be new ones yeah
and here's one that I'm working through
right now I didn't think that I could
make a YouTube channel in Norwegian and
you're watching this video of me in
Norwegian I didn't think this would
happen so I do that stuff on the podcast
and like I share a lot of stuff for my
personal life and challenges and all the
stuff I learn uh I just you know now I'm
getting this a vision of how this is
going to go into the YouTube channel
yeah which is nice because it's so much
easier to make content like that than to
like plan out something the hardest part
is the think that what you're doing is
worth talking about CU you're just doing
it yeah and it doesn't feel big no your
YouTube channel doesn't feel big that's
everyday life yeah but it's not for most
people right like it's crazy what you're
doing yeah who else is doing this in
Norway who else has a personal
development channel in Norwegian and is
making videos three times a week sharing
like no one no one no so it's crazy but
we don't think of it as crazy true
coming here is crazy but you don't think
of it as crazy true so that's the
hardest part is finding a story that
that you think is just whatever but
other people would actually find really
inspiring awesome yeah I mean the
comments might help right like oh my God
you're doing that like oh oh yeah I
guess that is kind of a big deal so far
there are no comments on the YouTube
channel only from your team which is
this is great which is even better like
lean into how does that make you feel
right it's like nobody's left a comment
except Evans team and don't they don't
even understand
Norwegian but I think if you stay
consistent on those three things the the
thought leadership videos the document
the process and then the the coaching
yeah and just making sure that it's
always coming out yeah and so getting a
little bit ahead on the schedule so that
even if you haven't done a coaching
video in a while you still have a
backlog to be able to release if I don't
see a coaching video for a while then I
don't know that you're a coach yeah and
if I only see you doing interviews and I
think you're an interviewer right the
interview would be a fourth like bonus
series if it helps cool you do it if you
don't want to do it doesn't matter if it
leads to business relationships awesome
but that won't be as consistent as like
every week has to be cuz those are
harder to a book too yeah you need the
right people their time may not line up
you might be traveling for you to film a
video walking back to your hotel you
could do it right yeah to book a guest
walking back to your hotel so any guest
stuff is when it happens and it's also
the least important series on the
channel and uh back to the old question
uh like okay email I sent out a weekly
email so do I because I don't want to
link to too much stuff in the email or
that's like I would put both or say Hey
listen to the podcast or watch it on
YouTube yeah cuz there's content it's
like here's what you're going to learn
I'm going to talk about boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom and then there's the
extra YouTube film also so there's the
podcast in audio and on YouTube and then
there's the extra uh YouTube film how
often you s emailing your your list once
a week once a week yeah for now I just
keep it with once a week yeah and put
all three in there or like or even just
the one even just the podcast one with
the the YouTube link yeah you don't need
to overwhelm or bombard people you don't
need every video to go out to your email
list true so if the podcast one is the
most important one just keep it what it
is now have the link to the YouTube
video make sure the link goes to the
playlist of all your other
videos and that's a good starting point
and do you have any other good ideas for
promoting the YouTube
channel like something smart ultimately
what we want to do is be able to win in
inside of YouTube yeah so pulling from
our existing list email is usually the
best M um you can create a campaign
around that you're launching like when
you have enough videos that you're proud
of you have coaching videos you have you
know the three series you could do a a
email campaign to say I'm launching I
launched my new YouTube channel here are
some of the videos that you should go
watch and you have a an email like that
I'd also look at inside of your
autoresponder sequence when people first
get onto your emails what kind of value
you bringing and what videos do you want
to put in there like you might record
special videos for the channel just to
be hit in your autoresponder sequence
yeah when they first come on I look at
any promotions you're doing and does it
fit in the PS like PS we have a video
talking about limiting beliefs or
whatever so I don't want to do too much
new like I think launching a channel is
a great thing to make an announcement of
but otherwise like how do you fit the
YouTube channel into what you're
currently doing yeah instead of having
to create a ton of new work and
ultimately then it just becomes I'm
making the videos good enough that
people consume them so before woring
about promoting like crazy let's make
sure people are watching them who are
going and that they're good and that
they're good because if they're watching
them they're good then the algorithm
starts to kick in as well so it's less
about having to do tons of promotion
more about making great videos that
people want to watch so you already have
a good chunk of videos then it's looking
at the retention curve and the
clickthrough rate and all that so that's
the best part of YouTube versus a
podcast is the promotion takes care of
itself once the content gets good enough
yeah for the podcast you have to keep
pumping out because it doesn't have
built-in
distribution I like it all right so
people want to find your channel and
they speak Norwegian where are they
going that's Anakin Vin that's my name
really all right we'll link it Up Down
Below Anakin thank you for the
love to watch me coach another
Mastermind member oneon-one check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I had 5 years to get
to 2,000 subscribers or something like
that the only thing I had going for me
was I just kept going it wasn't very
good on camera I didn't have any
strategy I didn't really know what I was
doing I felt insecure all the time